let's give ourselves an overview er
synthesis of all that we've learned
about plant and animal cells and what I
have over here on the left this is
supposed to be indicative of an animal
cell animal cell and what I have on the
right this should be indicative of a
plant cell plant cell so let's start
with the what's outside of the cell so
we see in both of them we see the
extracellular matrix you see on this
animal or outside of this animal cell
you see all these collagen fibers and
everything else and all these fibers
that are holding these cells into place
and allow the cells to relate to each
other and actually the depending on
what's inside of it can even help signal
different things to the cells so this is
an extra cellular matrix now when we
think about the extracellular matrix for
our plant cell we also think about the
some of the components that are involved
in the actual cell wall and so the cell
wall is a key difference between plant
and animal cells so cell the cell wall
is going to be in a plant cell animal
cells don't have cell walls now if we go
one layer deeper we get to the plasma
membrane the cellular membrane and we
see that that is common to both the
animal cell is going to have a plasma
membrane and the and the plant cell is
going to have a plasma membrane and they
actually can both have tunnels from
neighboring cells or tunnels between
neighboring cells we studied that in the
cell wall video for plant cells we saw
these things right over here called
plasmodesmata and we actually see a
complete one over here because I start
to draw a little bit of an adjacent cell
plasma plasmodesmata does mater and in
animal cells the analog R gap junctions
which are still tunnels between adjacent
cells
so gap gap junctions now plasmodesmata
are much more common to a much wider
category of plant cells than gap
junctions but gap junctions can be very
relevant in certain types of animal
cells in particular things like heart
cells where because of gap junctions
between adjacent cells electrical
signals can move through the tissue and
let adjacent cells know hey it's
time to contract in the right way so
this is still very crucial for certain
types of animal cells so now let's go a
little layer even deeper actually before
I do that I want to re-emphasize this
and I do this in almost every video all
of these membranes that we draw either
the outer cellular membrane or the
membranes of these organelles these are
all lipid bilayers or phospholipid
bilayers so if I were to zoom in right
over there on this yellow place right
over there it looks just like a line but
it really is it really is a they really
are these phospholipid these
phospholipid bilayers that have these
hydrophilic heads that point outwards
and these hydrophobic tails that pleat
inwards and it keeps going I want to
make that very clear these lipid
bilayers all of these membranes that I
draw are lipid bilayers but let's keep
on going so as we go now into the cell
we see that both of these cells have
cytoskeletons I have cytoskeletons so
you have your micro filaments right over
here microfilaments right over here and
I'm not giving full justice to the
complexity just because we want to be
able to have a fairly simple looking
diagram you have your micro tubules
micro tubules you might have
intermediate filaments and we talked
about all of those things in other
videos but now let's dig a little bit a
little bit deeper so in the animal cells
I have these centrosomes and they are
key for organizing the micro tubules and
we're going to see them a lot when we
talk about mitosis we don't see them in
plant cells they actually figure out
ways other ways to organize their
microtubules especially well in general
and especially even when we're thinking
about something like mitosis but let's
see what other differences are here well
one big thing that you might notice is
this big blue balloon egg looking thing
and it doesn't contain these green
things it's really just behind these
green things and this is these tend to
be associated with plant and fungal
cells this is a central vacuole central
vacuole and a central vacuole can store
fluid it can store enzymes it can be
viewed as a place for waste
and it actually turns out that even
though they're common to plants that
depending on which plants which cells
they can have very different roles and I
want to emphasize this to you and I do
this in other videos we keep seeing all
these organelles and we can draw
pictures we can draw diagrams of them
and we think we know what most of their
functions are but almost all of these
organelles and all of actually the cell
is area whether it's an area of active
research you know in the decades to come
we're going to find more and more things
that these different organelles do in
ways that they signal to each other and
interact with each other and behave in
different circumstances so we're
starting to understand what's there and
have an idea of what they do but in the
decades to come we're going to learn
much much much more about the different
structures and functions of a cell but
as I mentioned this is central vacuole
big it's large it can help provide
structural support for the cell can help
store things and the best analog on the
animal cells some animal cells actually
can have a vacuole not not all of them
but the best analog is the lysosome so
this right over just in the orange color
this right over here is a lysosome
lysosome lysosome and a lysosome could
be viewed as the waste disposal of an
animal cell where it's going to have a
bunch of of enzymes in it so that things
can kind of go in there and get broken
up it has a low relatively low pH of a
more acidic pH so that things can be
broken up in different ways and then
there their individual pieces can be
recycled and since we're in this
category if places where things go to
get maybe broken down or catabolized or
metabolized in certain ways it's also
worth talking about the peroxisomes
peroxisomes pair roc citizens
so the peroxisomes we actually see in
both of them and they're named that way
because when they were first studied
they said hey there's something going on
here where the there's some oxidation
reactions going on here it seems like
the final byproduct seems to be hydrogen
peroxide and so that's why they were
named peroxisomes
and we're still understanding exactly
all of the things that they do but we
know that they're important for for for
cutting up long-chain fatty acids so
that they can be more usable by other
parts
of the cells but they also have other
roles and all of their all of their
mechanisms are still not still not fully
understood now going back to differences
between the plant cell and the animal
cell a key difference is going to be
these characters right over here these
are chloroplasts this is where
photosynthesis takes place and clearly
we're going to show it in the plant cell
this is how they take they are able to
create they're able to create
essentially a fluid or or I guess you
could say fix carbon based on light
energy so let me see chloroplast chloro
chloroplast right over there we do not
see that in the animal cell now when
we're talking about energy we talk about
the ATP factories of cells and we find
this in both of these cells and that of
course are the mitochondria and we see
the mitochondria in both of the cells
and then the other things we also see a
lot of common things we see a Golgi we
see the Golgi apparatus in that cell we
see Golgi apparatus in that cell and
that's where we package proteins for use
either within the cell or outside of the
cell we have the endoplasmic reticulum
we have the rough endoplasmic reticulum
that has ribosomes bound to the membrane
and we have the smooth where you don't
have the ribosomes and this is where a
lot of proteins get manufactured but
include and all but even lipids also can
get manufactured then you have of course
the nuclear membrane actually this is
the inner nuclear membrane right over
here the outer nuclear membrane is
contiguous with the endoplasmic
reticulum but you see that in both of
these cells and inside of course you
have the DNA it's in chromatin form and
then you have this kind of extra dense
root area that shows up in microscopes
which we call the nucleolus which is
associated which is associated with
ribosomal with ribosome formations and
ribosomal RNA and of course you also
have free ribosomes free you also have
free ribosomes so this is a very
high-level overview of cells eukaryotic
cells I should say but hopefully it also
starts to show you some of the key
distinctions between animal and plant
cells